foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
is this based off the one Japanese show
we were watching that one video where
there's two guys were in a naked spa and
then the recliner church just go back
but I love that
I see one where they have like hammers
in front of them they just flings up and
hits them in the balls like that type of
[ __ ]
the funniest part about those videos is
the door during weather going down
foreign
have you seen that [ __ ] prank where
it's one actor I don't know if he's
Japanese Korean probably Japanese
um where wherever he would it was like
an ongoing prank they were doing this
one actor and they would make it so that
the floor was fake and he would always
fall into a super hot water oh hot water
it was like a continuous no it was
everywhere oh [ __ ] always [ __ ] up have
you seen this oh David David showed this
[ __ ] to me we're like literally and he
would be like Paranoid on set and he was
like there would be scenes where he
would like be in a cool suit bro and
he'd be walking through a [ __ ]
regular ass like hallway and [ __ ] and he
won't even like the floor would just
break and he fall into the hot water and
there's one where there's one where
literally he's all paranoid after like a
shoot he gets on to like the [ __ ] um
the shuttle to take him back to the
hotel and the door the shuttle opens up
and he falls into a thing of hot water
he's just like and he's like man he's
like he's like [ __ ] is it so hot is he
ever like what who's doing this [ __ ]
he's always like super confused always
part of the show right no no no no he he
no [ __ ] with the producer yeah like he
knows that like it's part of like this
thing that happens to him but he'll be
on set for other [ __ ] right but like
he's part of like uh like he's a
producer of this is he like is he like
jackass like he's like it's like a Stevo
I don't think that's it
then what is he there for he's an actor
and they just keep [ __ ] with him
and there's one there's one clip I mean
I gotta find it for you guys he goes to
accept an awards so he bet and he's
literally walking on stage
[Music]
why is it going to be hot water every
time and why does that make me laugh so
much yes yes because you visibly see can
we watch it in but like he's in pain
when he goes it's so hot I don't know
which one's worse hot water or cold
water ah we gotta find it personally is
hot hot for me because it burns you cold
you just gotta can't even do like for
you guys like Jacuzzi hot is too hot for
me like we Spa the hot the hot tub [ __ ]
no I'd rather fall into hot than cold
for sure hot feels good though no I'd
rather be pulling cold the ease is
all kind of it's like oh is it cooking
hot like that like diving into that we
Spa hot is hot that's gonna be shocking
yeah yeah but also cold yeah true
they're both both are pretty crazy yeah
yeah that's crazy how like in Japan PTSD
isn't even like doesn't exist it exists
they ignore it sounds like they laugh at
it actually which is a really healthy
way of dealing with things I think all
right so back to Wipeout here I'm going
to show you guys a quick like trailer of
this show so you get an idea of this
specific show the the non-japanese one
oh that's not gonna be as hardcore well
let's see oh it's British people it
might be actually
[Music]
oh I've seen this song
In Search of Pride and Glory well some
Glory but mainly the 10 grand prize
and the prince of Preston Mr Freddie
flings off as we relive the greatest
game show on the face of the Earth
welcome to Total Wi-Fi I feel like this
is something you would do Joe I would
want to do it I don't know if I'd last
oh it's a different show because this is
the British version yeah this is the
British version but that's the same idea
the same idea but it's like Ninja
Warrior but less skill and more like
you're just getting pummeled there's no
pride in it yeah so anyway wipe out uh
recently they were filming and one of
the contestants after completing the
show's obstacle course
died oh what after completing it wait on
the show yeah like how well they were
filming the show so he won he won it
like he like he he actually finished it
no I I read this article before he even
did the thing he was he was feeling like
like Heart Like breathing or heart
problems or some [ __ ] like yeah he took
too much pre-workout [ __ ] I don't know
but apparently he went into cardiac
arrest and he was taken to the hospital
he must be athletic then he finished the
whole course that's the thing so
contestants before even participating on
the show they pass a a medical exam and
there's also two paramedics on set along
with safety of safety producer and a
paramedic coordinator so like they do
their best to make sure like everyone's
safe you got a whole stash yeah yeah but
unfortunately like this guy he ended up
having a heart attack and dying on on
set pretty much that's crazy dying on
Wipeout that is so Bonkers yeah you know
what else is crazy too is that there and
back in 2009 another Wipeout competitor
had died and this dude he was a 33 year
old who had initially complained of knee
pain while participating in an obstacle
course and then uh after he completed it
he ended up going to the hospital and he
died of a stroke two weeks later one
with that one that one was like super
rare because he ended up having this
like really really rare condition where
uh so it's their fault he had like a
like this thing called APS and it's like
the syndrome which ends up it gives you
like reoccurring clotting throughout
your body but it's like tiny little ones
so a lot of people don't even realize
that they have it and so it he ended up
having like a premature stroke and a
heart attack and all that stuff what
kind of
rigorous things are they doing oh he's
done a marathon before this 33 year old
from 2009 like he was very athletic and
he had actually been participating in
Wipeout with his wife on this like
couples so it's it's just like fit
people that never knew that they had
these complications until Wipeout so
it's just like freak accidents it seems
sounds like that yeah it sounds like
it's just yeah freak accidents for like
natural causing accident yeah sure I
know because it's not like on the show
they hit their head and died like that
would be way different I think it's not
like you know they're walking into a
room and they're falling in the hot
water can we watch it can you find a
compilation please I wouldn't even know
what to search do you think type in
Japanese hot water falling prank yeah
all the words yeah do you think that the
guy was actually getting a real award or
they just you know it's hard to say
especially since it's all in Japanese or
Korean or whatever do they do those kind
of prank shows in Korea I would assume
that it's just oh maybe that's it oh my
God maybe that's it because a lot of
Japanese uh shows would
do that to their produce like not
producers but like an eight minute video
so obviously it's probably a compilation
look
oh he's a convenient
oh [ __ ] yeah
damn
so that's how you know it's hot about
how he's [ __ ] like scrambling to get
out
is that what it said oh dude I used to
watch these guys
they're both yeah they're a [ __ ]
they're a Duo man they've been they're
like Thanksgiving
to look forward
it's realistic he's in the samurai
outfit yes I think he's on set for some
of the shoot that's why he's like so
unexpected
[Laughter]
yeah
or something yeah I could scrub yeah
those guys are comedians they're not
behind the scenes guys
awesome but they probably just well why
does Joe have to give us the context it
was so perfect
they do that there's another one where
they [ __ ] with this
um girl and guy that they were trying to
connect like hook up and then they're
both like in the dressing room or
something and the whole floor
basically goes down like a ramp and then
both of them slide down together and
then they put them on a date oh wow but
like yeah is the guy getting pranked a
comedian too that guy yeah he's a
comedian so like I don't know he's just
on set and they're [ __ ] with them
this is the the bus one it says three
moments later
foreign
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how the [ __ ] did they know that you have
to set that whole thing up so that he's
got nowhere else to sit maybe there's a
Stakeout maybe there's a Stakeout they
were like he always sits in that
bathroom tragically maybe he's not on it
me and Joe just ruined this whole thing
you guys are no fun over there I know
oh
yeah
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] if if it is staged what the
[ __ ] is he doing boiling himself every
single [ __ ] time that's the best yeah
that is funny traumatic comedy is like
one of the funniest things even for that
right so you have an award show who were
they putting the mic after that where
was the mic before that I don't know
they just gotta you know they just gotta
move the mic a little bit dude that's
all or there was no word choke that's
the only thing they shot and they they
left possibly I believe there's a ward
show never know I don't know we'll never
know we'll never know usually in these
they they tell you how they set it up so
then you everyone's in no judge a joke
no we'll never know we'll never know
it's it's impossible to know
[Music]
foreign
[Music]